anita
where are you
[Music]
no matter what
we get each other home
jackson
whoa sergeant you made it
that enemy pilot got you good
what
what's the zipper
where's lieutenant williams wait hold on
wait where are you going
the fridge
that's not possible
what the hell
benito thank god it's okay
it's okay
we're safe now
what happened
gridiron was a massacre
but we're alive sis
that's what matters
they called a retreat but just a few of
us got back to the hestia
made it and try to jump and here we are
edge of the galaxy
the outlands
no no no no that can't be right
we would never let gridiron fall
you were out a long time the war's over
we can start a new life here
what are you talking about this is enemy
territory what are you doing reporting
in
there's no way back
sergeant williams
i need you to put out an sos to any imc
friendlies on an encrypted signal
crew of the ims hestia requesting
immediate evac i detect no imc
signatures within range just do it
there's got to be someone left
there's got to be
our family's been fighting this war for
generations
here
that made me one on my first deploy
congrats you're an active duty williams
now
jackie
no matter what
we get each other home
[Music]
to the imc
to family
[Music]
[Music]
jackson
[Music]
the fight isn't over it is for us
[Music]
you lied to me
there was no retreat
well
there should have been
damn coward
you didn't see what i saw
we were dying for a lost cause and they
knew it then that was the mission
we're soldiers
that's what we signed up for
i signed up to protect my family
the imc never gave a damn about us
neither open your eyes
i have
[Music]
lieutenant williams
you are a traitor to the imc
the penalty for this session is death
sir you promised leniency i'll give him
a quicker death than he deserves
sir he deserves a hearing we have to
escort him back to criticize don't be
naive soldier for the imc to survive
it must be perched a weakness
get out of here neither
i can't let you do this sir
this is wrong
such a waste
jackson
i'm good
aah
not bad
the williams family heroes of the imc
decorated soldiers for generations
[Music]
imagine your parents disappointment when
they learned their children died as
traitors and cowards
[Music]
uh
[Music]
i'm so sorry
you did what you thought was right
we both did
the imc will never stop coming for me
then we keep moving
i could be running the rest of my life
i can't ask you to sign up for that you
don't have to
[Music]
we're family
[Music]
[Music]
you